[Musique]
une grande kermesse une fête champêtre
où il est de bon ton d'abord un
couvre-chef insolites et le verbe est
haut
voilà comment se présente le national de
pétanque très lu dans ce rendez vous de
la fin juillet organisée par notre
confrère le provence n'anticipons pas
pendant quatre jours tous que la
provence compte deux champions et de
boulistes du dimanche les boulistes de
cabanons a envahi le parc borély écrasée
de lumière et de chaleur ont désigné du
doigt les grandes vedettes qui sont
d'ailleurs dans la plupart des quatre
communes aux deux spécialités du jas
pétanque et du jeu provençal également
appelé le jeu à la long sous les
frondaisons la question est revenue sur
le tapis
oui ou non le jeu de boules peut-il être
considéré comme un sport à part entière
lucienne d'apo directeur des services
sportifs du provençal ainsi la tête et
mettre des gigantesques ballet du parc
borély a fait le point très franchement
de discipline qui n'ont pas des
différences essentielles mais dont on
peut dire à propos de la première
ascension de la pétanque à reconstituer
un amusement
quant à la seconde jeu à la longue
alors là le caractère sportif de l'as de
la discipline interviennent avec son
goût des couleurs voyantes ses coups de
gueule ses silences son sens du théâtre
le monde bouliste semble constituer une
véritable phone i nous tease et par le
bouchon et la danse des boules autour de
ce centre de gravité toutes les classes
sociales sont représentées dans ce
concours par exemple et hier il y avait
trois professeurs de médecine qui était
et qui forme une équipe
une équipe d'avocats y avec ses terres
etc et de fait des pdg alors des
artistes en nombre les artistes aussi il
n'y a donc plus une faune comme aux
audits de jours de boules la comédien
bolliger mètres de là réservé à tout le
monde les gens prennent le chat alors ce
qu'ils aiment ça au sérieux et la
compétition a la même valeur sur le plan
moral que dans les autres disciplines
sportives le jeu à pétanque engendre
bien moins que la longue la scène
cocasse le geste théâtre plus facile et
plus rapide
il ne permet pas aux comédiens de donner
la pleine mesure de leur talent pagnol
est à bien y réfléchir il ya peut-être
une certaine philosophie dans le jeu de
boules qui échappe à l'oeil du profane
[Musique]
je suis persuadé que vous avez
personnellement tirer si j'ose dire une
philosophie de toutes ces journées de
boules que ce soit la pétanque quoi la
longue philosophie et les thermaux ans
qui fait un service pour nos listes
mais il est évident que la karaka que ce
soir à paris surtout dans le jeu est
longue et bien différent de ce qu'il
était autrefois dans un songe maintenant
à de véritables compétitions des
compétitions aussi dur aussi approché
dans tous les autres sports il n'y a
qu'à voir de quelle manière allez
joueurs se préparent pour des finales
d'ailleurs aussi bien pétanque à la
langue pour cerner les tricheurs un
appareil tout simple un rail la boule
truc est farcie comme disent les
boulistes s'arrête sur le rail comme
elle dégringole pas sur une pente mais
le président du shon veille et les
boulistes qui ont essayé d'enfreindre le
règlement ont toujours été sanctionné
par la commission de discipline 40 45
ans qui sont venus chez moi et plomb et
commun comme une gosse
et vous qui avez la réputation d'être
très sévères vous êtes laissé attendrir
par cb je me lassais thoniers ont pas ce
que je n'espère que je suis moi-même
baudis et je reconnais qu'après trois
ans la hiérarchie n'a pas été respectée
hier si l'on en croit les spécialistes
albert qu'à la note ile-napoléon déboule
avait connu le matin même un waterloo
retentissent en finale une équipe de
sorts de composés de humblot père et
fils et de massana chemises rouges
étaient là pour rappeler aux spectateurs
quand vaucluse après le travail des
champs la pétanque constituent
l'essentiel des loisirs et qu'il faut
toujours compter avec les champions
inconnus qui n'ont pas l'occasion de se
mesurer souvent aux vedettes
l'autre équipe de belles chemises plus
clair était constituée par pal mérignies
pana et bien qu'ils ne les b roy se sont
imposé d'entrée ils ont même mené par 9
1 puis par 12 à 4 il y a eu un sursaut
des sorgues et qui se sont approchés de
leurs adversaires tout ça n'est ce
finalement l'équipe de perles a remporté
le national de pétanque 1973 par 15 à 10
victoire amplement méritée au terme
d'une finale
issue d'une bonne qualité technique
[Musique]